bien fait rire en tenons donc
pertinemment où j'ai joué des films
comiques et où je pense qu'on est pas
trop mal tiré
et quand je vais dans les allées que
j'écoutais gens rire sur un acteur
comique si on veut mais où tous les
acteurs doivent être des acteurs
comiques et en même temps des acteurs
dramatiques pendant quelques années je
pensais de cinéma ce que je fais autre
chose notamment j'écrivais des chansons
chose que j'aime bien promener un peu
dans la vie quoi et puis voilà blanc
depuis l'année dernière où j'avais fait
en mode collègues de bronze cas les
choses on nous ont redémarré producteurs
sont souvenus que je fais des fines
je fais ce film là je m'en faire un jour
je vais refaire la suite de tendre
poulet ce genre brouille qui nous plaît
ah oui mais je me suis beaucoup amusé à
tourner ce crime
vraiment il y adeux laventure il ya de
l'humour
ja s'est jamais vulgaire c'est un
comique simple qui me plaît qui est très
sain et il ya du mouvement il ya des
dépôts paysage vin reste vraiment en
plus quand on tourne en extérieur dans
le sahara en plein été il se passe des
tas de choses et une aventure c'est une
aventure de tout le monde doit de faire
un film